let's go to the phones on a very, very busy
news week.
(617) 830-4750.
We will start with our caller from the three
one two area code.
Let's go to our caller from the three one,
two.
Hi David.
This is Priscilla from Chicago.
How are you?
Good.
So the question just, I had a thought when
I was at the store.
I see that you've major corporations, you
know, always ask before you pay.
Um, you know, we were willing to donate two,
$3, um, to a good cause it ends up being a
good cause, but it just rubs me the wrong
way because it's like you're a multibillion
dollar corporation.
Why don't you donate $1 billion to this corporation
instead of asking two or $3 from people who
are already maybe lower middle class, middle
class.
And you know, when I talk about it to people,
their reaction seems to be kind of mixed.
Like they're kind of torn because it is a
good cause like the children's hospital.
But I don't get past the fact that these are
still billionaires asking for two, $3.
Well, the big one is, um, I, I, I totally
agree with you and I am mixed in a sense because
I, I'm not saying that the cause isn't a good
one.
I'm not saying that the issue of, you know,
childhood cancer is, is not an issue that
we should be taking seriously and, and working
to solve and you need money to solve that.
Um, or hunger for example.
But when I go to whole foods and you know,
that whole foods was, you know, trying to
prevent having to give employees healthcare
under Obamacare and all this different stuff,
and then they're like, Hey, will you round
up your purchase or give us $1 or $5 for this
or that?
It's like, are you seriously asking me for
that given what you have been doing?
But at the same time, I don't want to suggest,
I don't care about the cause because I do,
it is a really weird thing and I think it
works on guilt a lot.
They want to guilt people into making these
donations.
They use like, you know, a child's hospital,
which usually deals with like cancer and kids.
And so you feel torn and you want to donate.
But at the same time I feel angry because
it's already like you've taken so much and
I feel like the middle class, the poorest
people, you know, lower class, they shouldn't
be putting in more, you know, I feel like
it's a great cause then you put in more.
Absolutely.
Now let me ask you, Priscilla, do you ever
do the donations?
You know, I used to, but I feel like as I
got older I think I got angrier.
Like just got more cynical, I feel.
Um, and I just, I felt like their care for
people as not really genuine.
Um, so if I do do donations, I do directly
to the organizations versus going through
like, you know, whole foods or Walmart or
anyone who offers like that.
That's exactly what I do and know.
Part of it is when charities are a big uh,
area of scams.
And I want to make sure that not only is the
money getting to the charity, but I want to
make sure that the charity is also using the
money in a way that's responsible.
So whenever I'm asked for any donation and
if it's at the grocery store, I just say,
no thank you.
But if I'm asked on the street or if someone
comes to the door soliciting, I always say,
listen, the way I decide is I proactively
seek out organizations that share my mission
and values and I make a contribution to them
after I've researched them.
And those are my donations for the year.
I don't like on a whim throw another five
or $10 at this or that thing.
I think about, I put time into it and that's
what I do.
That's it.
And I feel like they've been doing it a lot
with like the hospitals now too.
Like from my hospital, I am getting a lot
of like, Hey, donate, you know, $5 to this
good cause and it's you guys already charged
an arm and a leg to be seen there.
And there's still, I mean
beyond that then you know, talking about donating
to hospitals, given the for profit private
insurance system that we have, I mean it's
a mess.
That's a, that's a complete other story for
a different day.
But very good point.
Priscilla, I appreciate you calling in and
making it.
Thank you so much for taking my call.
David.
I'm a long time listener.
Thank you.
Hope to hear from you again.
I appreciate it.